watch this here so
watch this this is they're spraying
jp morgan chase's building
[Music]
is this in new york where is this
addison
texas no no this is new york watch
[Music]
first of all good for him so far so far
he's looking good
[Music]
all right buddy it's about to get
interesting in about seven seconds
six five
four three two
one oh my gosh
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh that's not blood by the way
it looks like blood it's not blood it's
ink
no that's how antifa bleeds black blood
wow it's a pretty bad situation
okay press pause uh
ricky thoughts god oh my god
you know um
i got a lot of thoughts about it i think
that uh i think a lot of people
we're so we're so spoiled here that
that people don't that people don't
understand these anti-capitalist
socialist
people don't understand how bad other
countries have it and
they come here and they want to do these
stupid little protests like this
um by the way you know how many how many
i mean
how many how many cars have been bought
by people
that couldn't afford them cash that
chase funded they gave them a loan
how many businesses hasn't been started
because of chase how many houses have
not been bought because of chase
i mean it's just crazy to think that
people would actually go against
a a a a corporation that
literally allows you to fund your dream
well if your dream is to own your first
car
chase will fund it your dream is owned a
business chase will fund it
you know obviously you have to fall into
some requirements you want to own a home
chase you'll fund it
it's crazy how uh people would literally
want to bite the hand that feeds them
it's it's amazing to me um but you know
it's uh these these socialists people
with social
socialist ideas are just ah man they're
a special breed
adam what do you want to say about this
i mean uh i mean i have a
lot of respect for jamie dimon the ceo
of jpmorgan chase
and um that guy's an idiot and uh you're
gonna scale a wall or scale
a uh a building and i mean
i hope he's got a good health insurance
hopefully maybe he's on obamacare
i think some i think these people pat
you know what we got to do to them we
need to give them a one-way ticket
to whatever country that has socialism
that they like
like i would love to start that that
that foundation
you know the the one i'll be called the
one-way foundation you want to send them
to venezuela wherever they want to go
except here yes go to scandinavia
wherever you think the socialist country
is
let's send you over there i mean if it's
so great right in america so he will
just go give us
go uh we'll have you jump on the plane
we'll have
the flight attendant retrieve your
passport and then just uh just take off
just take off and then we'll make sure
we'll call the embassy all down there
let them know that you don't need
another passport because you have no
intentions of coming back to such an
evil country
right to say to this evil empire right
just go
just take off we don't need you here so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you